شكرا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل هذه
التغطيه للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا ساعه بعد اخرى
تخف اصوات انين من بقي تحت الانقاب لترتفع
اصوات الدعاء ان يخرجوا سالمين من تحت
ركام الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا
ايام مره لتتضائل معها فرص العثور على
ناجين تحت الانقارب الا ان الامل باق هي
خمسه ايام رفعت عدد الضحايا في تركيا الى
اكثر من 19000 قتيل فيما تجاوز عدد الجرحى
سبعه وسبعين الف مصاب ومن نجا من الزلزال
ضربه التشرد حيث تم اجلاء اكثر من 75 الفا
من المناطق المنكوبه في اكبر كارثه زلزال
شهدتها المنطقه عبر التاريخ
اما في سوريا فالزلزال الذي طال خمسه
محافظات او بحياه اكثر من اربعه الاف شخص
حتى الان في حين توقع المرصد السوري ان
يتجاوز عدد الضحايا هذا الرقم
وتشير المعلومات القادمه من هناك ان
المستشفيات تغص بالجثث فيما يسابق عمال
الاغاثه الوقت للعثور على احياء تحت
الانقاض
[موسيقى]
هذا وقالت منظمه القوه البيضاء ان فرص
العالقين تحت الانقاد في سوريا بالبقايا
احياء نادره جدا بعد 180 ساعات على
الزلزال واكدت المنظمه في مؤتمر صحفي انها
ستواصل عمليات البحث والانقاذ بحثا عن
ناجي ان فرص العالقين تحت الانقاض بالبقاء
على قيد الحياه نادره جدا بعد مرور مئه
وثماني ساعات
سنستمر في عمليات البحث ولن نتوقف لانقاذ
من تبقى
[موسيقى]
في عمليات الهدم الذي تحصل هكذا يكون
عمليات هرس للجسم مما يؤدي الى عمليه الى
نزيف في الجسم مما يؤدي الى حاله وفاله
هذا تمكنت فرق الانقاذ في قهرمان مرعش من
انقاذ طفله تبلغ من العمر 13 13 عاما بعد
بقائها لمده 99 ساعه تحت الركام وخلال
عمليه الانقاذ التي استغرقت 10 ساعات تحدث
رجال الانقاذ باستمرار مع الفتاه وطرحوا
عليها اسئله لابقائها واعيا كما كان منها
الا ان طلبت منهم اسمعها اغنيه مفضله لها
وقالت انها مشتاقه لتناول الايس كريم
[موسيقى]
هيئه اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
اعلنت انه تم اجلاء اكثر من 28 الف شخص من
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال منهم اكثر من
4600 عن طريق البر والسكك الحديديه واكثر
من 24 الفا عن طريق الجو
وبحسب الهيئه سيتم وضع الاشخاص الذين تم
اجلائهم في مناطق الاقامه التي حددتها
مكاتب الولايات واداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه
لا تخاف تمام
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
طالعين
اذهب الى القامشلي مجددا ينضم الي من هناك
لمزيد من المتابعه مراسل العربيه جمعه
جمعه اهلا وسهلا بك لو تنقل لنا الصوره
ابرز مشاهداتك في هذه الاوقات جمعه وكيف
تسير عمليات الاغاثه والانقاذ
طلب العنوان الابرز لهذا النهار كان تجمدت
عمليات يعني يعني
الحصول على اصوات من الناجين تحت الانقاض
يعني خلال 24 ساعه وحتى الان لم يتم انقاذ
اي شخص اخر من تحت الانقاب في المدن
السوريه المنكوبه الاربعه حلب وحمى
ادلب وايضا طرطوس يعني لم يتم العثور على
اي ناجين تحت الالقاب رغم انه عمليات فرق
البحث والانقاذ استمرت حتى
هذه اللحظات كل ما تم انتشاله هم جثث اكثر
الجثث تم انشالها في مدينه اللاذقيه كان
عدد القتلى
383 ارتفع العدد الى 58 يعني في حصيله
كبيره جدا وهو ما رفع اعداد القتا في
سوريا الى حوالي
4,120 شخص حتى الان طبعا
لا يزال هناك يعني الاف المصابين يعانون
من جروحهم واصاباتهم في حين بدات الادويه
والمعدات الطبيه يعني تقريبا تنتهي في
اغلب المشافي والنقاط الطبيه حتى بعض
الاطباء كانوا يقولون لي بانهم اللي
يستخدمون القفاز نفسه لاكثر من عشر مرات
حتى يحترق لانه لن يجدوا قفازات الطبيه
رغم انها رخيصه لكنها غاليه لانها غير
موجوده في شمال غرب
البلاد جمعه انا مضطر ان اسالك هذه
الاسئله واعرف ان الاجوبه قاسيه في هذه
الاوقات نحن نتحدث عن ضحايا بالالاف هؤلاء
طب كيف يتم التعرف عليهم على جثثهم كيف
يتم دفنهم من يتابع اوضاع ذويهم خصوصا
ابنائهم ونحن نعرف ان كثير من هؤلاء
الابناء هم قصه
صحيح امام كل منزل تحول الى ركام هناك عدد
من الاهالي عندما يتم انتشال الجثه يطلب
من الاهالي يعني من الساكنين في هذا
المنزل او من الذين اتوا من المناطق بعيده
لمعرفه مصير اقاربهم ينظرون الى الجثه
عندما تكون يعني يتم التعرف اليها يتم
اصطحابها من قبل الاهالي غسلها ثم يعني
دفنها غالبا ما يتم الدفن في مراسم اي
مراسم جماعيه وفي مقابر جماعيه في في جميع
المدن الماكوبه خاصه في ارياف حلب اما
الذين لا يكون لديهم اهل امام الم
بدا اثناء استخراج الجثه تحول الى المشافي
ويعذب الاهالي الى المشافي للتعرف عليهم
حتى الان هناك 90 جثه مجهوله الهويه في
مشافي ادلب
وعفرين 90 جثه لم يتعرف عليها احد تركت
جثثهم في مجال في ادلب وعفرين وربما تصار
الى الدفن يوم انا لا احد يتعرف عليهم
هكذا يتم التعرف على الجثه الطالب طيب
جمعه في اطفال فقدوا اهاليهم وذويهم حتى
اقاربهم طب هؤلاء من يهتم بهم يعني نحن
نتحدث عن اطفال يهيمون بدون ماوى
معظمهم في المشافي وهناك يعني دور خاصه
لرعايه الايتام عددها قليل جدا يعني حتى
عددها او لا ايضا لا يبدو كبيرا مقارنه
يعني بالامور الاخرى يعني ربما عددهم يعني
اقل من 25 طفل لم يتعرف عليهم احد لكنهم
في المشاف يتلقون العلاج او نقلوهم الى
دور رعايه الايتام هناك يعني تصلنا حتى
نحن عدد كبير من الطلبات لتبني هؤلاء
الاطفال وايضا نلاحظ على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي رغبه لعدد كبير من الفنانين
الممثلين للرجال الاعمال بتبني هؤلاء
الاطفال طيب جمعه اكثر من منظمه دوليه
حذرت من عوده تفشي الكوليرا في الشمال
السوري نتيجه هذا الزلزال لانه مياه الشفا
ومياه الشرب اما تلوثت اما غير مؤمنه الى
اي مدى يعني هذا الكلام له ارضيه يعني في
المخاوف هذه جديه ام لا ترى انه يعني مياه
الشرب مؤمنه للناس
يعني حالات الاصابه المؤكده للكورونا وصلت
في عموم سوريا الى 74 الف حاله قبل
الزلزالة قبل حوالي 15 يوم من الزلزال كان
هناك احصائيه تتحدث عن 74 الف اصابه
بالكورونا معظمها في يعني شرق شرق وغرب
الفرات اي في مناطق الاداره الذاتيه
ومناطق المعارضه وايضا في يعني المناطق
غرب الفرات في دير الزور والميادين
والبوكمال هذه الحالات تم التعامل معها من
قبل منظمه الصحه العالميه وايضا من قبل
الهلال الاحمر الكردي والهلال الاحمر
السوري وايضا الدفاع المدني والقطاعات
الصحيه المختصه لكن لم يتم القضاء على هذه
المشكله هناك الالاف لا يزالون يعانون من
البوليرا والتبعات هذا هذا الوباء
وبالتالي جاء زلزال ليفاقم اصلا مشاكل
القطاع الصحي ويحول الاهتمام من الامراض
الاعتياديه يعني الامراض الشتويه
والكوليرا والاوبئه التي كانت قائمه الى
المصابين الى نوع اخر الى المصابين وهم
مصابين الزلزال الذين يعانون من جروح
وكسور وفشل كلوي وما الى هنالك من الامراض
التي نجمت او الاصابات التي نجمت من هذا
الزلزال من القميص لمراسل العربيه جمعه
كاش دائما شكرا جزيلا لك ويعطيك العافيه
جمعه على هذه المتابعه وعلى نقل لنا
الصوره اولا باول
الى متى يمكن للعالقين البقاء تحت الانقاض
وضعيه الشخصيه عند حدوث الانهيار فمن
المهم تواجد الشخص في مكان بحمايه جسديه
الحصول على الماء والهواء فهما اساسيان
للبقاء على قيد الحياه
ومن الضروري عدم الاصابه بالجفاف لرفع
احتماليه البقاء على قيد الحياه
بعض التقديرات تشير الى امكانيه بعض الناس
العيش دون ماء لمده تتراوح بين الثلاثه
وسبعه ايام
مستوى الاصابات فقدان الدم او الكسور
يقللان احتماليه البقاء حيا لاكثر من يوم
خصوصا اذا تعرض الشخص لصدمه في الراس او
اصابات في العمود الفقري او الصدر او تضرر
العضلات نتيجه السحق
الظروف الجويه خبراء يقولون ان ظروف
الشتاء تجعل الوضع اسوا بكثير
السرعه التي يحدث بها انخفاض حراره الجسم
ستعتمد على مدى عزله الشخص او مقدار
الماوى الذي يتمتع به ولكن في نهايه المطر
سيصاب العديد من الاشخاص الاقل حظا
بانخفاض حراره الجسم في ظل هذه الظروف
القوه العقليه والنفسيه خبراء يشددون على
اهميه الحفاظ على الاراده النفسيه
والعقليه المركزه على البقاء قد يكون امرا
حاسما للبقاء على قيد الحياه كما قالوا
انه من المهم السيطره على النفس والتقليل
من الذعر للتقليل من الحركه الجسديه
لتوفير الطاقه
وداع ثاني يخشى الستيني السوري بدر الدين
ان يكون ابديا هذه المره مع شقيقيه
المهاجرين الى انطاكيا في تركيا
ولدين فقد اي اتصال معهما منذ وقوع
الزلزال
ومنذ ذلك الوقت يرابط بدر الدين امام معبر
باب الهوى بين سوريا وتركيا عله يحصل على
خبر يحدد مصير شقيقي
وخلال انتظاره الطويل شاهد بدر الدين
اشخاصا يصلون من تركيا حاملين اكياسا
بيضاء وسوداء بداخلها جثامين لمهاجرين
سوريين قضوا في الزلزال الذي ضرب الجنوب
التركي والشمال السوري الاثنين الماضي
فرق الطوارئ في سوريا اكدت ان العديد من
المنازل في مدينه حلب التي تلقت الضربه
الاكثر الى من الزلزال تضررت بشكل كبير او
انهارت تماما
وبحسب الفرق لا يزال الكثير من السكان
عالقين تحت انقراض البنايات في حلب التي
يقيم فيها ملايين اللاجئين الذين تشردوا
بعدما افقدتهم الحرب الاهليه منازلهم
واشارت تقارير الى ان بعض الناس في
المنطقه اصبحوا بلا منزل 20 مره بسبب
الحرب الاهليه السوريه التي اندلعت في
العام
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه اعلن من جهته ان
مخزونه ينفد في شمال غرب سوريا داعيا الى
فتح المزيد من المعابر الحدوديه من تركيا
الى الشمال السوري حيث يعتمد 90% من
السكان على المساعدات الانسانيه وقد اكد
المدير الاقليمي لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا كورن فلاشر
ان هناك حاجه الى تشديد هذا المخزون
كلنا امن بالله
وملائكته وكتبه ورسله
لا نفرق
[موسيقى]
والسلام ولا تحزن علينا اثرا كما هملته
على الذين
هم
ما لا طاقه لنا
واغفر لنا وارحمنا
في محاولات اطقم الانقاذ البحث عن ناجين
تحت الانقاض برزت عده طرق يستخدمونها اكثر
من غيرها نتعرف عليها مع مراسلنا زيدان
زنجلو من اضنه جنوب تركيا في المواقع
المدمره نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
تعتمد فرق الانقاذ على عده طرق للتاكد مما
اذا كان هناك ناجين تحت الانقاض ام لا
اولا الطريقه التقليديه التي يقوم من
خلالها احد رجال الانقاذ باصدار نداءات
متكرره بعد فتح فجوه بين الركام وينتظر
حتى يسمع ردا من الداخل في حال لم يصله رد
تلجا الفرق الى الطريقه الثانيه وهي
الكلاب المدربه التي تستشعر وجود احياء
كذلك تلجا فرق الانقاذ الى استخدام
كاميرات المراقبه الحراريه التي تستطيع
تحديد اماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض طبعا
نحن نصور هذا التقرير بعد انتهاء تطبيق
هذه الطرق لان الصمت والهدوء التام شرط
الاساسي لنجاح هذه الطرق زيدان زنجلو اضنه
وزيدان يبقى معي من اضنه زيدان يعطيك الف
عافيه جديد المشهد من عندك اخر عمليات
الاغاثه وانقاذ واخر ما وصلت من ارقام
زيدان
نعم هنا في اضنه يتوقع المسؤولون اقتراب
عمليات
ازاله الانقاض والبحث عن ناجين قريبا انقل
تصريح لرئيس بلديه اضنه زيدان كارالار
الذي اكد وجود او انهيار احد عشر مبنى في
ولايه اضنه وتصدع 26 مبنى بعد بحث اول
وفحص اول من قبل السلطات المختصه هنا بحسب
رئيس بلديه اضنه تم الانتهاء تماما من
ازاله الانقاض في موقعين اثنين وجاري
العمل في المواقع التسعه الباقيه حتى
ينتهي العمل بسرعه وبعد هذا بعد انتهاء
العمل هنا سيصار الى نقل الطواقم طواقم
الانقاذ الاجنبيه
والمحليه التي تعمل في اضنه الى المناطق
الاكثر تضررا ونعتقد ان هذه الطواقم
ستتوجه الى هاتاي او كهرمان مرعش او يتم
توزيع الطواقم بين هاتين الولايتين
بالعموم بحسب رئيس البلديه عدد الضحايا في
اض نه تجاوز 400 ضحيه حتى هذه اللحظه او
حتى تصريح او توقيت تصريح رئيس البلديه ما
يعني طالما ان اعمال
ازاله الانقاض والبحث عن ناجين او حتى عن
جثث ما زالت مستمره لذلك الحصيله مرشحه
للارتفاع مع الاسف جهود الانقاذ تتواصل
طوال ساعات الليل دون توقف في كل المواقع
تقريبا التي بقيت هنا في مدينه اضنه التي
تحولت الى مركز دعم لوجستي لبقيه المناطق
غالبيه المساعدات تاتي الى هنا الى مطار
اضنه ومن ثم يتم توزيعها حسب المناطق
المتضرره وايضا طواقم الانقاذ التي تاتي
الى هذه الى مطار اضنه يتم ارسالهم مباشره
الى المراكز المدمره طيب زيدان شبكات
الكهرباء الهاتف محطات المياه الى اي مدى
هي متضرره سواء بشكل جزئي او كلي في اضنك
قبل ان اسالك عن موضوع اخر هو موضوع نقص
المعدات المخصصه
لمثل هكذا حالات
نعم بدايه يعني كما تشاهد هنا في هذا الحي
الذي نتواجد فيه لا كهرباء ابدا يعني ظلام
يلف المنطقه بالكامل لان شبكه الكهرباء
تضررت في هذا الحي بشكل كبير بقيه الاحياء
وبعض بقيه المواقع تقريبا لا توجد مشكله
في الكهرباء خدمات الكهرباء والماء وايضا
خدمات حتى الانترنت هذه الامور متوفره لكن
هناك انقطاعات في او هناك نقص في او
انقطاعات كهرباء في بعض المواقع المدمره
كما في هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه الان
طبعا هذا الوضع لماذا لان اضنه لم تتعرض
او لم تتاثر بشكل كبير كما تاثرت في بقيه
الولايات كما تاثرت بقيه الولايات كهاتاي
وكهرمان مرعش نعم هناك اضرار وعدد ضحايا
كبير في اضنه لكن لا يقارن بحجم الدمار
الموجود في هاتاي او في كهرمان مرعش حيث
هناك تقريبا غالبيه المناطق غابت عنها
الكهرباء وايضا خدمات الانترنت
وخدمات اخرى كثيره لكن هنا الوضع افضل
نوعا ما او افضل بكثير من تلك الولايات
طيب زين يعني انا حدث فقط عن اضنه بس مثلا
عنها خرمان مرعش هل دائما هنالك يعني نوع
من الانتقاد انه جميع الفرق ليس لديها
المعدات الثقيله اللازمه المخصصه للحفر
يعني في وسائل حفر معينه لمثل هكذا حالات
انه الفرق التركيه او كثير من الفرق
التركيه لم يكن لديها مثل هكذا معدات الى
مدى هذا الكلام دقيق يعني رافعات معينه
جرافات معينه مخصصه لمثل هكذا زلازل
نعم لا شك هذا الموضوع اثير كثيرا خلال
الايام الماضيه حتى ان الايام الاولى او
الساعات الاولى من وقوع الكارثه في هاتاي
كثير من الاهالي تحدثوا انهم لم يجدوا حتى
فرق انقاذ تساعدهم هم هم انتشروا جثامين
اقربائهم من تلك من بعض المواقع في هاتاي
حقيقه يعني وهذا كان يتحدث عنه الرئيس
اردوغان كان هناك قصور في الساعات الاولى
على ما يبدو ارتباك كان من حجم الكارثه
كان هناك نقص في المعدات خصوصا في
الولايات المتضرره نتحدث عن هاتاي وكهش
وما زاد الوضع سوءا او وصول المعدات
اللازمه كانت انقطاع الطرق بسبب
الانهيارات التي جرت في بعض الطرق المؤديه
الى ولايه هاتاي والى ولايه غازي عنتاب
كان هناك تضرر كبير في بعض الطرق سواء
كانت الطرق السريعه او حتى الطرق البديله
او الطرق الفرعيه ايضا كان فيها التضرر
نعم لا شك ان هناك على ما يبدو ان ولايه
بتاعي لم تكن مستعده لكارثه من هذا الحجم
ربما لم يكن في الحسبان ان يكون حجم
الدمار في هذه على هذه الشاكله حقيقه
الجميع صدم بحجم الدمار فيها تاي وانا
اتحدث هنا عن هاتاي لانها حتى الان
المدينه الاكثر
دمرا بحسب الاحصائيات تقريبا ثلث المباني
المدمره في هاتاي ثلث عدد الضحايا في
هاتاي ولذلك الموضوع كان كبيرا حتى ان
مطار هاتاي تضرر نتيجه الزلزال ما اعاق
ايضا وصول مساعدات جويه طبعا الاليات
الثقيله لا يمكن ارسالها على السلطات
ارسالها برا كما ذكرنا اعيق وصول او تاخر
وصول الاليات اما للظروف الجويه السيئه
ايضا هذه النقطه لم نتحدث عنها تراكم
الثلوج في عدد من المناطق وانهيار المباني
او انهيار عفوا الطرق في مناطق اخرى
من اضنه زيدان زنك لمراسل العربيه دائما
شكرا جزيلا لك زيدان على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
هذا وزاره الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد احدى
المناطق المنكوبه في حلب حيث اظهرته الصور
وهو يخاطب مجموعه من رجال الانقاذ في اول
زياره معلنه له الى المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال كما اعلنت الرئاسه السوريه ان
الاسد زار مستشفى حلب الجامعي برفقه زوجته
الى ذلك توقع التقارير غربيه استمرار
كارثه الزلزال في تركيا بسبب مخاطر اخرى
حتى بعد معالجه الجرحى وانتشال جثث
الضحايا من تحت الانقاب هذه التقارير نبهت
الى امكانيه بروز تداعيات اخرى بفعل
الزلزال مثل نقص المياه النظيفه والتعطل
شبكه الصرف الصحي فضلا عن انخفاض حاد في
درجات الحراره وتلوث المياه الجوفيه لافته
الى ان سكان المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
يواجهون صعوبات في العثور على المياه
الصالحه للشرب ويخشون انتشار الامراض لا
سيما المعديه منها كما تخشى المنظمات
الانسانيه خصوصا انتشارا وباء الكوليرا
الذي عاد للظهور قبل فتره
فيشو
المتحدث الرسمي باسم منظمه اليونيسف في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا عمار
عمار قال ان الاطفال يمرون بظروف ماساويه
في المناطق التي وقع بها الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا وشدد المسؤول على ان الاوضاع
الانسانيه في سوريا على وجه التحديد صعبه
جدا حيث اشارت التقديرات قبل الزلزال الى
ان هناك نحو ثلثي السكان بحاجه الى تقديم
المساعده والعون ومن بينهم سبعه ملايين
الطفل يحتاجون الى المساعده الانسانيه
التي تتركز على توفير التغذيه المناسبه
والصحه والحمايه ومياه الشرب الصالحه
وغيرها وقد جاء الزلزال يفاقم الماساه حسب
قوله
الخوذ البيضاء اعلنت انها ستواصل البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاض رغم صعوبه الامر
فالزلزال يدخل يومه الخامس ما يعادل 120
ساعه
حتميا فرص نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض شبه
معدومه حيث تعتبر اول اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
بعد الزلزال اي اول ثلاثه ايام اطارا
زمنيا حرجا
وينخفض بعد ذلك معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه الى ما بين خمسه وعشره بالمئه
وبحسب خبراء الكوارث الطارئه تعتبر
الاثنتان والسبعون ساعه الاولى بعد
الكارثه هي الفتره التي يمكن للانسان ان
يعيش خلالها
بقوه جسديه دون طعام وماء ويبلغ معدل
البقاء على قيد الحياه 90% خلال اول 24
ساعه وخمسين بالمئه الى 60% بين 25 و 48
ساعه وعشرين بالمئه الى ثلاثين بالمئه بين
واثنتين وسبعين ساعه اما بعد الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه فيكون معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه ما بين خمسه الى عشره بالمئه او
اقل
وفي الكوارث عاده ما يتم الغاء معظم جهود
الانقاذ بعد خمسه الى سبعه ايام فالعثور
على شخص ما خلال هذه الساعات الذهبيه كما
توصف هي مساله حياه او موت
وتعتبر سباقا
مع الزمن
الى القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا معي
من هناك مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن استزرامي اهلا وسهلا بك
بدايه اخر تحديث لعدد الضحايا
والارقام التي تصلكم او ترددكم خصوصا وانك
توقعت ارتفاعا كبيرا في عدد الضحايا في
الساعات والايام المقبله يعني هون عن اي
رقم نتحدث قد تصل اليه قد يصل اليه عدد
الضحايا
لا نتحدث مساء الخير نتحدث عن الرقم
الحالي وهو وصل للنحو 4500 بشكل قطعي
السوريين داخل الاراضي السوريه فقط ولا
نتحدث عن النفيذه جاء بهم التركيه وهم
ليسوا 640 هم 975 دخلوا من بعبر باب الهوى
الى الاراضي السوريه والارقام هذه ارقام
ليست نهائيه ولن تكون نهائيه بسبب استمرار
وجود مفقودين داخل في تحت الانقراض في
هناك قرى كثيره دعني نتحدث لماذا الحصيله
تختلف ما بين المرصد واخرين ان هناك كثير
من القرى لم تصلها فرق الدفاع المدني وجرى
مباراه السره للضحايا من قبل الاهالي في
الريف عفرين ايضا في مناطق سيطره النظام
نتذكرنا بان هناك 21 بلده وقريه في ريف
ادلب الشرقي وريف حلب الجنوبي ايضا كان
هناك فيها ضحايا مباراههم في عده قرى
الارقام كبيره وكبيره جدا وهنا مثل ما
ذكرت في التقرير الامل الان يعني الا
الهيه قد نعثر على احياء تحت ركام وليس
تحت انقاذ تحت ركام المباني التي انهارت
بشكل كامل اذا ما قلنا في مدينه حلب التي
زارها بشار الاسد اليوم وكان يبتسم
حقيقه الامر يعني العالم يبكي على الشعب
السوري وبشار الاسد يتحدث الاعلام وليبتسم
ويضحك يعني اين النكته في هذا الامر لا
نعلم نعود الى حلب الشرقيه مباني باكملها
رغم وجود فرق انقاذ عربيه لم يبدا العمل
فيها
لمساعده من هم معلقين تحت هذا المباني
ايضا ليس بعيدا عن القرداحه طب لماذا لان
يعني هناك كثير من المباني لكن هارت حقيقه
الامر كثير من المباني التيارات النظام لا
يملك الماسوره المازوت سابقا سرق لتجار
الحرب ولا نملك الوقود حقيقه الامر من اجل
ان تستمر الاليات جاءت فرق عربيه تعمل قدر
الامكان لكن هناك مباني يعني انهارت بشكل
كامل لا يعلم بشار الاسد اذا كما هذه
المباني يوجد يعني اجساد لمواطنين ام لا
يوجد ان كثير من المباني كانت هي بالاساس
ايه للسقوط حقيقه الامر رغم ذلك كان يقتل
فيها المواطنين
نعود الى الشمال الى شمال غرب حقيقه الامر
يعني منطقه مثل منطقه جنديرس الى الان
هناك عشرات المبانيين لم تتمكن فرق الدفاع
المدني لان لا يوجد امكانيه كبيره لديها
الجماعه يعني اشتغلوا يعني عملوا بشكل
كبير جدا ليلا نهارا حاول بمنطقه وباخرى
الى ان تدخل السيد المراد ابو محمد
الجولاني وجاء باحد الاليات لكي تصعد على
ركاب احد المباني كي تحاول البحث عن
المدنيين هل من الماخون انت لا علاقه لا
علاقه لك بالفرق الانقاذ لباسا يعني موجود
جنب هذه الاليه لذلك اقول هناك عشوائيه في
بعض الاحيان
يريدون التبرعات هون اذا توقعاتك ان تصل
يعني حصيله الضحايا يعني بشكل
اكثر من 6000 بشكل قطعي اكثر من 6000 وهذا
ما كنا نتوقعه ليس في اليومين الاولانيين
بعد ذلك قلنا العدسه يرتفع الى اكثر من
6000 وهنا نتحدث عن حصيله ليست نهائيه
ليست الارقام مثلما يقال ثلاثه الاف
وخمسمائه
اذا لدينا احصائيات نحن في الاسماء اكثر
من 4000 يعني حتى اللحظه في الاسماء اكثر
من 4000 من الذين احصائيات هناك بلدان
ناجحه نجح منها الكثيرون الى ادلب يوجد
فيها اكثر من 130 و 180 لارقام ماهوله
يعني انت يعني نزحت الى هذه المنطقه خوفا
من القصف ويفاجئك الزلزال ويتخاذل المجتمع
الدولي عليك
انك تموت تحتها هذه الارقام كمان سؤال
كمان اريد ما تصلك من معلومات حقيقه ما
يجري على معبر باب الهوى صليب الاحمر قال
انه الحكومه السوريه سمحت بمرور المساعدات
وانه المساعدات مرت بشكل سلس البعض يشكك
يقول يعني في الطرفين في الوضع مش مش ضابط
كما يقال بالدارج اي معلومات تردك عن ما
يجري على معبر باب الهوى وهل فعلا في
اتصالات تجري يقوم بها طرف ثالث بين
الحكومه التركيه والحكومه السوريه من اجل
فتح معابر اخرى
فتح معابر اخر الان دخلت قافله من اقليم
كردستان العراق بالمؤسسه البرازاني دخلت
عبر معبر باب السلامه وصلت الى عفرين
المنكوبه اذا منطقه جنديرس هذه القافله
عبرت من معبر
[موسيقى]
من
القوات ان تدخل
عبرها قافله عبرات فان قوائف اخرى قادره
على ان تعبر هل مؤسسه البرنساني تستطيع
ادخال قافله مساعدات والامم المتحده لا
تستطيع استخدام هذا المعبر من اجل ادخال
المساعدات اعتقد الان والمضحك الان يا
سيدي الكريم بان الفيارق الوطنيه بدات
بتبرعاتها في اليوم الخامس لضحايا الزلزال
وبداوا بنصب القيم التي كانت في
مستودعاتهم بشكل كبير جدا مع الصوت
والصوره لكي نقول بانهم يعملون من اجل
الشعب السوري طيب ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
القاهره مدير المرسل السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
هذا وتجمع الجاليات التركيه والسوريه في
المانيا مساعدات لارسالها لمناطق الزلزال
وفيما تنسق الجمعيات التركيه لارسال
المساعدات عبر السفاره التركيه فان مهمه
الجمعيات السوريه اصعب ومصير المساعدات
التي يتم جمعها غير واضح
منذ ان بدات اخباره الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا تتوالى الى المانيا بدات الجليات
التركيه والسوريه بتجميع المساعدات
لارسالها الى المناطق المنكوبه وهذا واحد
من اماكن تجميع هذه المساعدات في منطقة
كريت باك واسط برلين في وسط المنطقه التي
تعد معقل الجاليه التركيه في العاصمه
الالمانيه تحول المعهد التركي للموسي ق
الى مركز لجمع وفرز المساعدات التي يتبرع
بها سكان المدينه الى المنكوبين في تركيا
كلنا جئنا الى هنا للمساعده هناك عدد كبير
من الاشخاص ياتون يوميا ويملاون الصناديق
ويشرفون على تجميعها طوال اليوم ومعهد
الموسيقى التركي هنا يتواصل مع السفاره
التركيه والقنصليه التي ستنقل هذه
المساعدات في الشاحنات وتدقق فيها قبل ان
ترسلها الى تركيا على متن طائره تابعه
للخطوط الجويه التركيه
وفيما تجمع الجاليه التركيه في المانيا
نفسها لتقديم ما امكن من المساعدات
استنفرت الجاليه السوريه هناك ذلك وفتحت
الكثير من المراكز الثقافيه والاجتماعيه
ابوابها لجمع التبرعات وارسالها الى سوريا
مثل جمعيه سلام رغم ان المهمه هنا اصعب
بكثير وارساله هذه المساعدات ما زال غير
مضمون نحن عملنا
هذا التجميع للمساعدات لنقل الشمال السوري
وجنوب تركيا حيث اللاجئين والمناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال راح نجتمع راح مع
جمعيات صديقه تركيه مؤسسات ومؤسسات دوليا
نسق معه بحيث المواد هاي اتصال باسرع وقت
ممكن للناس المتضررين وفي تضارب كثير في
المعلومات بصراحه ما في معلومات دقيقه نحن
على التواصل مع شركائنا في الداخل او
الحدود واي معلومه تصل تفتح المعابر اكيد
الاغراض الموجوده هون في المانيا ما راح
تصل خلال 24 ساعه على سوريا ولكن نحن
بنجهز اذا وصلتنا اي اشاره بدخول مواد
لسوريا بحيث يكون جاهزين ولكن صعوبه
الوصول الى كل المناطق السوريه المتضرره
يعني بان هذه المساعدات قد لا تصل للجميع
والجمعيه هنا تقول انها لا تملك اليه
لايصال المساعدات لمناطق معينه وان هدفها
انساني ويتمثل بايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين
في الشمال السوري وجنوب تركيا راغبنان
العربيه برلين
بعد مرور نحو 103 ساعات على محاصرته تحت
الانقاض رجل يبلغ من العمر 66 عاما ينجو
من الموت بعد العثور عليه من قبل قوات
الانقاذ في تركيا
[موسيقى]
قافله اولى من المساعدات مؤلفه من ست
شاحنات دخلت الى مناطق سيطرتي فصائل
المعارضه في شمال غرب سوريا من تركيا عبر
معبر باب الهوى الحدودي واوضحت المنظمه
الدوريه للهجره ان القافله تحمل بطانيات
وفرشات وخيما ومستلزمات طوارئ ومصابيح
تعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه وذلك لتغطيه حاجات
ما لا يقل عن 5000 شخص الا ان منظمه الخوذ
البيضاء اعربت عن خيبه املها معتبره ان
المساعدات الامميه التي يجري الحديث عن
دخولها هي مساعدات دوريه وقد توقفت خلال
الايام الاولى من الزلزال والان تم
استئنافها على صعيد اخر كشف مسؤول تركي ان
انقره تناقش اعاده فتح معبر حدودي يؤدي
الى مناطق خاضعه لسيطره الحكومه السوريه
ما يتيح ارسال مساعدات الاغاثه من الزلزال
مباشره الى هذه المناطق بعد عقد من العذاب
وقال المسؤول ان تركيا تدرس ايضا فتحا
معبر اخر الى منطقه ادلب السوريه الخاضعه
لسيطره مقاتل المعارضه
هذا واظهرت صور جويه اثارت دمار الهائل
الذي خلفه الزلزال في منطقه في ريف عفرين
شمالي حلب وهي من اكثر المناطق المتضرره
[موسيقى]
من المتابعه المدير الاقليمي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا الدكتور حسام
شرقاوي دكتور حسام اهلا وسهلا
في اخر الجهود التي تقومون بها مع جميع
الاطراف سواء في عمليات الاغاثه او
الانقاذ او ارسال المساعدات العينيه الى
المحتاجين وماذا عن المعابر
اشكرك انا عدت امس بعد زياره ثلاث ايام
لسوريا اطلع على الوضع
والمعونات العينيه التي توصل بطائرات
يوميا من عده دول العربيه السعوديه
الامارات الكويت العراق اردن مصر جزائر
وغيره ايران
يتم سريعا
اخلاء الطائرات
وانا تابعت الشاحنات التي تعبئ وترسل الى
الشمال في مناطق فيها وضع امني حساس في
مناطق وصلتها المعونات وهذا يدور 24 ساعه
الوضع ماساوي كما كل التقارير تفيد وبدات
تظهر حجم الدمار
بنحس الجميع انه نحط السياسه على جنب
ونركز على انقاذ الناس وتقديم المعونه
زملائنا في الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري
بحضروا القافره القافلات تتوجه يوم
الاثنين لمناطق ادلب
من داخل سوريا وليس من المعابر التي برضو
تاتي من تركيا وان شاء الله هذه المعونه
حتتوسع فيها
الوضع في تركيا برضه ماساوي والسلطات
التركيه طبعا
نتفهم تماما مبسلطين او مركزين دعمهم
للشعبهم ولاهلهم
فانا متفائل خير اليوم سمعنا برضه اخبار
كويسه من حكومه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
برفع الحصار عن التحويلات الماليه لمده
180 يوم
لمساعده
اغاثه
المنكوبين من هذا الزلزال
بدي اسالك دكتور حسام عن حجم الاستجابه
لنداءاتكم يعني كنت بلاش انت في الحديث
انه هذه استجابه
لنداءاتكم ولكن كيف تتاكدون من وصول هذه
المساعدات العينيه الى المحتاجين الى
الملهوفين الاله مثل هكذا
مساعدات خصوصا في سوريا نحن تعرف في سوريا
يعني في قوه فاعله هنا وقوه فاعله هناك هل
من تنسيق بين الاطراف لمرور هذه المساعدات
خصوصا الى الشمال السوري يعني منذ بعض
الوقت قال الصليب الاحمر انه بعبر باب
الهوى دخلت منه بعض
[موسيقى]
المساعدات وبالتنسيق مع الحكومه السوريه
انتم ما هي معلوماتكم
انا اليوم كان عندي لقاء مع كتير مسؤولين
في هذه الامم وشتى هيئاتها
لانزيد المعونات والنسق المعونات
ونبعد عن الازدواجيه
لدينا اتحاد دولي للجمعيات الهلال الاحمر
والصليب الاحمر فرق موجوده دائما قبل
الزلزال داخل سوريا وتتابع بشكل يومي
وفوري توزيع المعونات فاحنا عنا قناعه
تامه على انه هذا يتم بالتركيز على حاجات
الناس طبعا المعونات اللي وصلت لحد الان
لا تكفي ابدا حجم
الاحتياجات
فمازلنا نطالب المجتمع الدولي
بالتبرع اكثر واكثر سواء
عينيا او سواء كاش
يساعدنا برضو بشراء بعض الامور داخل سوريا
لانه في بعض الشغلات البطانيات وغيره
الخيم ممكن نلاقيها داخل صوره وبدانا
بتنفيذ هذا مع الاحمر العربي السوري
فالمرحله هذه احنا بنحكي على ايام بعد
زلزالين ضخمين ضرب المنطقه اي دوله اي
دوله في العالم
مهما كانت قدراتها حتواجد صعوبه انها توجه
الدعم فوري للجميع بس انا عندي قناعه تامه
بعد زيارتي انه العمليه تمشي على ما يرام
بتعرف انه هذه الماساه وهذه الفاجعه ستظل
ارهاصاتها معنا لاشهر وسنوات ما الذي
تحتاجونه سواء يعني في الايام المقبله في
الاشهر المقبله في السنه يعني وحتى في
السنوات المقبله نحن نتحدث عن مئات الالاف
من المشربين بدون ماوى نتحدث عن عشرات
الالاف ربما من الايتام من الاطفال طيب
هؤلاء يعني انتم الان هل لديكم خطه يعني
وضعتم خطه الان للتعامل مع هذه الارهاصات
اكيد اللي تفضلت فيه بالزبط تجربتنا في كل
العالم هذا ليس اول زلزال كحركه دوليه
احنا نتعامل معه تعاملنا مع زلزالات ضخمه
في هيتي ونيبال وباكستان وغيره
اليتامى واللي فقدوا
اطراف واللي حيحتاجوا دعم لسنوات لبناء
والعلاج النفسي اللي كتير فئات حتحتاجو
اعاده بناء وتاهيل بعض المستشفيات
والعيادات وغيره خططنا الان تطلب لسوريا
80 مليون دولار هدول تساعد
كمرحله اولى 300 الى 400 الف شخص ممكن
يزيدها بملايين بننسقها مع الاخرين وخطتنا
لمده سنتين وممكن تكون لمده اكثر من هكذا
حسب
الموارد والتمويل احنا بنعرف تماما انه
زلزال زي هذا التعافي منه سنوات وليس
اسابيع او اشهر
يعني نتمنى لكم كل التوفيق دكتور حسام في
هذه المهمه الانسانيه خصوصا في هذا الوقت
الحرج من بيروت المدير الاقليمي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا الدكتور عيسى
حسام الشرقاوي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
[موسيقى]
هذا وتوقعت وكاله فيتش للتصنيف الائتمانيه
انت تتجاوز الخسائر الاقتصاديه جراء
الزلزال ملياريرا دولار وقد تصل الى اربعه
مليارات دولار او اكثر حيث تعرضت الاف
المباني بما في ذلك منازل ومستشفيات فضلا
عن طرق وخطوط انابيب وبنيه تحتيه اخرى
لاضرار جسيمه واشارت وكاله اداره الكوارث
التركيه الى ان لديها 11 الفا
وثلاثمائه
واربعين بلاغا من انهيار مباني سكنيه وقد
تم التاكيد
5775 منها
في تركيا تحديدا قال الرئيس التركي طيب
اردوغان ان 6000 واربع مئه واربعه واربعين
مبنى دمرت بسبب الزلزال وان
944 مبدا انهار في غازي عنتاب وحدها
متعهدا باستكمال اعاده الاعمار في المنطقه
في غضون عام واحد
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قال خلال
زيارته لمدينه اليمن التركيه ان الدوله
ستعمل على مساعده اقارب المتوفين جراء
الزلزال واعاده الاعمار في اقصر وقت ممكن
اود ان اؤكد لاقارب المتوفين اننا
سنساعدكم في كل شيء على المتضررين الا
يقلقوا ابدا سنعيد الاعمار بكل الطرق وفي
اقصر وقت ممكن نحن نعمل على تكريس
امكانيات الدوله لتقديم المساعدات
هذا ويسعى رجال الانقاذ للاستعانه بكل ما
يمكن من حيوانات او ادوات للوصول الى
ناجين تحت الانقاب لا سيما ان عمليات
البحث خلال هذه الكوارث هي من اصعب عمليات
الانقاذ واكثرها تعقيدا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان ليستطيع صعود درجات عاليه هو التنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
حركات خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي
يكشف عن دقات القلب
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا الزمن اعل صوته
ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك الانقاض
بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول ولا
يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
الهوى الحدوديه الصحفي مصطفى النعيمي
مصطفى اهلا وسهلا بك اولا صوره ما يجري من
بعبر باب الهوى وهل فعلا بدات المساعدات
تدخل بشكل سلس بين المناطق يعني منطقه
سيطره الحكومه ومنطقه سيطره المعارضه ام
لا الامور ما زالت غامضه وغير واضحه
تحياتي لك استاذ طاهر والاستاذ المشاهدين
الكرام لا شك تحياتي لك استاذ طالب عفوا
والاستاذ المشاهدين الكرام نعم لا شك ان
هذه المساعدات بشكل عام بدات تصل تباعا
الى الداخل السوري عبر معبر باب الهوى
بالدرجه الاولى حيث رصدنا اليوم دخول 14
حافله اربعه عشر سياره شحن دخلت الى داخل
السوري وتم افراغ حمولتها وعادت من ثم الى
الداخل التركي كذلك ايضا هنالك قوافل
مساعدات انسانيه قادمه ايضا من تركيا
هنالك منظمات كمنظمه الاهاهات رصدت خروج
بعض الشاحنات التي افرخت حمولتها في
الداخل السوري فاعتقد بان المعبر يعمل
باقداقته القصوى وعلى مدار الساعه تحدثت
مع الكثير من المسؤولين او ممن يتواجدون
في داخل في داخل المعبد فقالوا لي بان
المعبر يعمل على مدار الساعه لا يوجد
هنالك تعطيل لاي من القوافل وحتى لا
للقوافل الامميه هنالك بوابه خاصه تعجل من
ادخالها بحيث لا يكون هنالك تعطي لكن
السبب الرئيسي في تعثر وصول القوافل
المساعدات الامميه المختصه باداره الكوارث
اعتقد هو ما حصل اليوم او ما حصل منذ
بدايه الزلزال في الطريق الدولي الرابط ما
بين كلا من معبر باب الهوى وكذلك ايضا
مدينه انطاكيا فعلت طريق الدولي هنالك
يعني هنالك اثار كبيره حصلت في المعبر
وقمت بجوله اثناء احدى النشرات مع احد
زملائك اليوم حيث اظهر حجم الدمار الكامل
في هذه الطريق دمار الهائل في هذا الطريق
قرابه اثنين كيلو متر مدمر بشكل شبه كامل
انهيارات قد تصل في بعض النقاط الى متر
ونصف انخفاض الطريق عن المستوى الذي كان
عليه ايضا تدمير الجسر كلها عوامل ادت الى
تحويل الطريق وفي حال تحويل الطريق طريق
كروي لا يتسع لحجم هذه المركبات التي تاتي
من خلاله لذلك قامت الفرق الفرق الخاصه
باعاده تاهيل الطرق اليوم يعني شاهدتها
وهي تقوم باعاده ترميم الطريق الدولي من
اجل البدء بخطوات عمليه لاعاده انسيابيه
هذه
القوافل باتجاه الشمال باتجاه شمال السوري
طبعا هنا تحدث عن منطقه جبل عفوا جسر
الحديد هذا الطريق الدولي الذي يربط ما
بين كل مدينه الريحانيه وكذلك ايضا منطقه
انطاكيا التي تعرض لاضرار جسيمه استاذ
مصطفى من يستلم هذه المساعدات من المنظمات
الدوليه ومن يقوم بتوزيعها
هنالك منظمه اسمها اكتد على سبيل المثال
وهنالك العديد من منظمات المحليه التي لها
تواصل مع المنظمات الامميه والتي تقوم
بجلب المساعدات وايصال النداءات الاستغاثه
على مدار الساعه من قبل
عبر ما يصلها من نداءات استغاثه في الداخل
السوري ومن ثم توصلها الى باقي دول العالم
وهذا ما حصل ايضا مع مؤسسه الدفاع المدني
يعني منذ اليوم الاول اعلنت بانها قد نفذ
لديها الوقود وبالتالي تحتاج للوقود ورصت
منذ اليوم الاول وحتى يومنا هذا قبل قليل
رصدت مجموعه من قوافل التي تحمل وقود دخلت
الى الاراضي السوريه طبعا تحمل ماده
المازوت الذي يختص بتشغيل اما الافران
واما الاليات الثقيله وكذلك ايضا
المستشفيات ربما هي بحاجه لكن هل خطوط
الجسر البري هذا الذي تم تشغيله يكفي
لحاجات الناس اعتقد حتى تركيا لديها مشكله
حقيقيه يعني نتحدث عن تدمير عشره مدن
وارصت دمار كبير هائل في هذه المنطقه
خيارات في المباني ايضا انا في مكاني مكان
ما اتواجد فيه ايضا بين الفينه والاخرى
يحصل هنالك هزات واثناء تصويري المباشر
حدثت مجموعه من ربما قد تكون بسبب الاليات
الثقيله او غيره لا اتذكر ذلك صار لدينا
حجز بانه في اي لحظه تحصل انهيار في كل
ارجاء تركيا في كل ارجاء هذه ساكتفي بهذا
القدر من معبر باب الهوى الحدوديه الصحفي
مصطفى النعيمي شكرا على هذه المتابعه
بعد خمسه ايام على وقوع الزلزال فرص
العثور على الناجين اصبحت مهمه مستحيله
ولكن اراده الحياه اقوى شاب تركي نجا من
الموت بعد 94 ساعه نتابع القصه
كبطل خرج مبتسما من تحت الركام فريق
الانقاذ رفع له تحيه الحياه بعد ان بقي
محاصرا 94 ساعه تحت الركام في غازي عنتاب
التركيه بالقرب من مركز الزلزال
عمليه انقاذ عدنان كركوت الذي يبلغ من
العمر 17 عاما كانت اشبهه بالمعجزه بعد ان
اصبحت عمليه البحث عن ناجين اشبه
بالمستحيل من حسن حظ عدنان ان والدته كانت
بانتظاره على عكس الاخرين ضمته الى صدرها
وبكى الاثنان فرحا بالعوده الى الحياه
ابتسامه عدنان لم تخفي الدموع في عينيه
وايمانه بالنجاه ساعده على البقاء على قيد
الحياه كما وصف ايامه الاربعه تحت الركام
قلب الام لم يتسع فرحا بعوده في ذاتي
كبدها
[موسيقى]
فخرجت من نافذه سياره الاسعاف لترحب
بالحياه من جديد محاسن حداره العربيه
هذا وكشف القائم باعمال السفاره السعوديه
في تركيا محمد الحربي عن العثور على جثه
المواطنه السعوديه المفقوده في موقع
المبنى الذي كانت تقيم به في انطاكيا حيث
تم انتشار الجثه والتعرف عليها من قبل
ذويها
وتم استلامها الجثه لدفنها
افاد مراسل العربيه في العراق بوصول قافله
مساعدات عبر معبر باب السلامه الى غرب
سوريا قادمه من اقليم كردستان واضاف
المراسل ان القافله تضم اثنتي عشره شاحنه
محمله بمواد اغاثيه وطبيه لمتضرري الزلزال
في مدينه جنديرس وعفرين
بس يجينا خبر عنهم ونقطع الاتصال فيهم
بيعرف هالشخصين يخبرنا عنهم
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين سنواصل معكم هذه التغطيه
للزلزال المدمر لكن نتوقف مع بعض الاخبار
الخاصه بالملفات الاخرى الان
فقد رفض مندوب روسيا الدائم لدى الامم
المتحده الشروط التي طرحتها في مبادره
السلام ووصفها بغير المقبوله واضاف
المندوب الروسيه ان كل المبادرات
الاوكرانيه سواء كانت في صيغه السلام او
قمه السلام هي قذائف فارغه تهدف فقط الى
التاثير الدعائي حسب تعبيره معتبرا انه من
الواضح ان الشروط المنصوصه عليها غير
مقبوله
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان
الدعوات الى تفتيت روسيا تتزايد في الغرب
مشددا على وقوف موسكو بحزم والمواجهه
بمستوى اقوى البروب اكد ايضا سعي بلاده
لتشكيل نظام متعدد الاقسام لخلق ظروف
خارجيه متساويه للتنميه الشامله وذلك في
الوقت الذي تتزايد فيه المحاولات للسيطره
على القضايا الدوليه والعلاقات الاقتصاديه
بشكل كامل على حد قوله
قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكسندر
نوفاك ان بلاده ستخفض انتاجها النفطي
بمقدار 500 الف برميل يوميا الشهر المقبل
وذلك في رد على قيام الغرب بوضع سقف لسعر
الخامه الروسي بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
واكد نوفاق ان بلاده لن تبيع النفط لاولئك
الذين يلتزمون بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
بسقف السعر حسب تعبيره وكانت مجموعه الدول
السبع قد وضعت حدا اقصى لسعر البرميل يبلغ
60 دولارا على النفط الروسي المشحون الى
دول غير غربيه
هذا واكد الجيش الاوكراني في بيانه اليومي
ان القوات الروسيه كثفت من هجماتها الجويه
على مناطق واسعه شرقي اوكرانيا تمهيدا
لهجوم بري واسع في الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع
الحرب
واضاف بيان الجيش الاوكراني ان مدينه
خاركاز تعرضت لقصف كثيف ليله البارحه فيما
اكد عمده زقروجيا ان المدينه تعرضت للقصف
سبعه عشره مره خلال ساعه واحده في محاوله
روسيه لاخماد الدفاعات الاوكرانيه قبل
تنفيذ هجوم شامل على شرق اوكرانيا
طالبت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه بان تتحمل
الولايات المتحده المسؤوليه اذا اثبت
وقوفها وراء تخريب خطي انابيب الغاز نوردو
ستريم 1 ونورد ستريم 2 في سبتمبر الماضي
واعتبرت الخارجيه الصينيه ان تلك
الانفجارات اثرت بشكل سلبي للغايه على
البيئه وسوق الطاقه العالميتين
تصريحات الخارجيه الصينيه جاءت تعليقا على
تقرير للصحفي الامريكي سايمر هرش بان
واشنطن وبمساعده اوسلو فجرت خطوط انابيب
الغاز التي تربط روسيا بالمانيا تحت بحر
البلطيق
اخيرا قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
المنطقه الصينيه الذي دخل المجال الجوي
لبلاده لم يشكل انتهاكا خطيرا للامن
القومي للولايات المتحده ولكنه يعتبر
انتهاكا للقوانين الدوريه كما اشار الرئيس
الامريكي ان جيش بلاده اتخذ قرارا حكيما
عندما قرر اسقاط المنطاد قباله سواحل
كارولينا الجنوبيه
حنين الشولي تلقاكم بعد قليل في مواصله
لهذه التغطيه للزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله